hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back I'm foreigner and today
we have tons of info to talk about the
new content of the week the Viking armor
the Wulin armor and the DLC characters
are all getting new armor with tons of
stuff coming next week so let's get
started with today's video so first up
we're gonna do the Vikings and then
afterwards move into the DLC characters
then after that we're gonna wrap up the
armor with the blue line' guys so let's
start with the Vikings the first Viking
we have up is warlord and he looks a lot
older in this outfit which really fits
his aesthetic as a warlord a character
usually they're known for being a lot
older and more masculine skulls on the
waistband belt and lots of leather armor
you can also have a more manly a younger
look but still having that muscular type
feel with a blond colored beard as well
to go along with the whole outfit
Valkyrie is next and sadly she still has
her mask on a lot of people believed in
myself included also believed that she
was going to have no mask but sadly
she's still going to keep her on but she
does have a little bit less armor it
seems on the chest and there's some fur
to replace that her hair is also shown a
little bit more and there's also a
couple tattoos near her wrist and elbow
as well she also has a tucked in cape
and less flashy looking mask so so all
in all not too bad but still I really
wish I would have loved to see her face
so that we can at least get something
like that but next is Raider and he has
a bag over his head now obviously this
isn't the only armor piece you get I
still think this is really funny a lot
of Raider main should definitely use
that just because it's funny but I
thought a lot of people won't lots of
love their armor and straps as it shows
his skin
a lot more he also has a few gold pieces
with actual armor on there as well and
some spikes on the helmet which is
really nice still I think the bag is
probably the funniest looking thing of
this armor set that he has so but do
what that as you will Berserker is next
up and he actually is unmasked this time
he has tons of chalk over his face with
some pieces of him having no boots in
just bare feet
a very war torn survivalist type look
for both genders as well same as usual
for the whole faction lots more leather
armor with seeing him is kind of creepy
though because I did expect them to be a
little bit younger than what was shown
but that could have just been me but
still assess to at least put a face to
the name and stuff like that I know that
he just had like a little mask over his
eyes we could still see his beard but as
long as we could see him fully without a
mask that's really cool and I do like
his type of face and how he looks so
personally to me that's what I think
moving on to the DLC characters we're
going to do the Vikings and first is
Highlander here's a lots of gem
on him and lots more for further than
before but do remember these are the DLC
characters and they're not getting a
whole new existing armor just variations
of the existing armor currently in the
game like I said the original cast is
getting whole new types of armor so if
you do play one of the original
characters you're gonna get all new type
of stuff but for the DLC guys you're
just gonna be getting variations of
older helmets chest pieces stuff like
that so if it looks less appealing
that's most likely while shaman has a
few different hairstyles and body paint
and are gonna be available for shaman
which is really nice very small
intricate details on the pants as well
and the occasional feather in her armor
I still believe she has a [ __ ] ton of
piercings and she probably has that sash
of finger somewhere on her on her body
somewhere strapped up on the belt but I
couldn't see that myself but still still
very deadly as always moving on to the
Knights our first up boy is Centurion
and he definitely has a cool looking
change different style mask with Tiger
fur on the back of his armor very big
shoulder pads as well some very small
details on the armor as well like just
like shaman but his helmets are also way
better and the older ones are still
looking as beautiful as ever I do like
the last tier armor I believe it's the
skull mask looks like a skull from
Halloween type stuff I personally think
that's going to be the armor a lot of
Centurions use just that helmet cuz it's
probably one of the best he has and just
from talking to other people sin turn
really doesn't have too much in terms of
customization everyone kind of looks the
same next up is gladiator and
technically his new mask is this lion
mask on him now small detailed patterns
on the armor just like Centurion and
shaman and he has a little bit more
silver tone on some armor but more gold
on some other pieces he still has
open-toed sandals so we're still gonna
be able to see his toes if any of you
cared about that and personally to me
since I play a lot of gladiator I do
like this lion mask I might keep my
original skull mask but personally this
might just be a thing I might use in
general because honestly it doesn't look
too bad so I still think he got some
decent armor for this rotation and then
the last two DLC characters we have this
shinobi in our Musha and shinobi has
different colors on his weapons and his
face matte giving in a lot more camo
looks which is really cool to look at
lots more detail on the pants like I
said the face mask has a lot of camo
stuff I don't know if it's gonna have
like a different type of variation or if
that's gonna change based on what type
of team you are because some of the
armor in the game changes colors
depending on what team or whatever color
palette you have on I'm not
we sure if that's going to be the
similar thing but hopefully it is
because that'd be really nice to see all
the different variations of people's
masks our Musha is the last DLC
character of the bunch and has a ton of
different colored pants and a lot of
tattoos very bright colored tattoos on
the chest as well many different
hairstyles and a lot some more different
hats you have to show off the opening in
his hat and leather armor inch straps of
course attached to his body [ __ ] like
that just normal stuff for the samurai
but I still think our Musha does look
very nice he I believe he still has the
same type of shoe where it's like that
that wooden type of sandal but still
lots of different armor pants tattoos
chest stuff like that so he's looking
really nice according to the devs they
stated that the armor will be an epic
and legendary tear variations for the
DLC characters and if you're using one
of the original cast you're going to be
able to unlock air from rare to
legendary friggin so take this with a
grain of salt because I don't remember
the actual colors and what they're
actually named but I believe epic and
legendary tier is the gold tier and the
teal tier the very last one with rare
two legendary being purple gold and then
teal I believe that's what the colors
are please don't quote me on that but
all of this stuff we'll be releasing on
October 16th just in case you guys know
on top of marching fire and all this
other stuff we're gonna be talking about
as well moving on we have the woolen
faction and T on Diaz first some of this
armor we've seen before from the other
dev streams in the open test but that's
the same for all the characters but
there is still a few we haven't seen yet
some armor has lots more metal and
headbands on him and somewhat even out
facial hair which is a little bit
awkward to look at so they're gonna
stick with the beard on him if I ever do
play him he also has a little bit of an
older version with a lot more white hair
and a longer beard still like I said
lots more metal and intricate designs
within the armor stuff like that to make
him feel like a real like type of
Guardian character neasha is next and
for her on showcased armor she has tons
of different hairstyles and some armor
with her hair covered but it's a long
ponytail going all the way down her back
she looks like a warrior from Persia
with this dusty type of color palette
but still it's nice nonetheless - and to
finish she also has a few face paints on
her face which can range from simply
just being over the eyes to a whole type
of look similar to Nobu she had from
last people with a slight difference
because I believe Japanese and Chinese
the whole geisha look is very different
so that's not exactly how Nobu sees is
just a little bit different
James hoon is third and has some larger
armor pieces with some
commendations of leather and metal
straps and pieces everywhere for tons of
customization for him with helmet
changes facial hair changes as well as
giving you tons of customization this
guy the higher you level him up the more
bulkier and the more his armors going to
get with shoulder pads intricate designs
of metal more gold armor and a lot of
other hanging ornaments coming off of
his body as well like little tassels and
stuff like that so he's gonna be looking
really cool at a high rank and then
lastly to end the lewin we have a
Shaolin his tattoos clothes hairstyle
and facial hair are all going to be
changing some variations having less
hair than normal more hair than normal
blonder colors and tons of tattoos or
even less tattoos depending on what you
pick
he even has some armor completely
covering his whole body as opposed to
the starter outfit where it's a lot just
like a tank top type out fare like a
short sleeve this more of a long sleeve
covering the whole base of his pants and
shirt and stuff like that there's also
going to be lots of ornaments hanging
off the armor and even a full mask to
represent I believe Wukong who I think
he is based off of the this mask is
gonna have tons of different colors and
facial differences personally this must
this personally to me is going to be a
must have for any Shaolin player I think
this is one of the best armors I've seen
so far today and this mask is really
cool it's got about four different
variations each simply some type of
animal a baboon a monkey stuff like that
so I cannot wait to see this in-game and
actually get this for myself
continuing on with the video we now have
the road map of October and it basically
the key points to look at is that on
October 11th the reveal stream event
livestream is going to be showing I
believe that is the week closest to
marching fire at least on the Thursday
so there's probably gonna be showing us
some new stuff maybe some new stuff I'm
not entirely sure the 14th
I believe this on the roadmap it's a
little bit wrong but the dev said that
on the 14th is when the season
officially ends so we'll see all the
ornaments stuff like that I'll have a
video showing off all that stuff as well
16th is the marching fire and the 25th
will have a new seasonal event which is
going to be awesome have no clue what
this is it's all blurred has some blue
and purple type of color so I'm really
excited for that and as well next week
this isn't shown on the roadmap but next
week they're gonna be showing off some
of the new weapon skins that are gonna
be coming to season 8
so I'll gladly show that for you guys
next week as well so stay tuned for on
this channel for that video and then to
end we have the content of the week and
it's going to be called elite outfits I
believe the names of us are drudes her
for the Vikings coats are no ha for the
samurai and eres Morrie Donny for the
Knights I butchered every one of those
names I'm so sorry about if I offended
anybody with that but their lead outfits
I believe they're around 7000 steel so
if you do want to get that you can
firstly to me not an elite outfit guy I
prefer mythic outfits or mask outfits
just that's just me though but if you do
want to get that you could definitely
grab it while you have the chance yeah
guys is going to be the end of the Vita
to hopefully you guys did enjoy thank
you so much for the support on last
week's video that [ __ ] had so many views
in such a little amount of time I think
it's at three hundred and twenty five
thousand views in just a week which is
way is that it's the most popular video
I've ever had on this channel and
there's so many of you guys and we got
like three thousand subs in the past
week so thank you all from the new
people that came on and all the old
people that still stuck with me as the
thing is so much for that video be hey
guys let me know what your favorite is
after seeing both videos of the nights
the Vikings Sam Wright all that stuff
let me know what your favorite faction
do you think has the best armor and with
that guys like the beef and do enjoy
subscribe for new I cover the
informational side a foreigner that
being balance changes hero updates patch
notes leaks all that type of stuff and
with that guys my two most recent videos
would be on the screen if you guys do
want to check that out
but that guys have a great rest your day
thank for watching the video and peace
out
[Music]
you
[Music]